madame la Première ministre avec
l'ensemble des députés du groupe liote
je voulais apporter mon soutien aux
commerçants aux forces de sécurité de
secours et aux habitants qui ont été
touchés par les violences de notre pays
évidemment à la famille duchenaël nous
condamnons toutes ces violences sans
réserve rien ne peut justifier
destruction et pillages il est une chose
cependant que j'ai appris de mes mandats
locaux l'action publique appelle
l'humilité
j'ai entendu des analyses de
pseudo-experts d'irresponsable politique
alimentant les discours de haine il n'y
a pas de solution miracle il y a une
urgence le retour au calme et alors puis
un chantier qui ne doit plus être
enterré celui d'une politique de
cohésion sociale on ne peut pas traiter
séparément les questions de sécurité des
réponses pénales des discriminations
d'accès à l'emploi de santé ou
d'éducation tout est lié il faut prendre
tous ces mots à la racine proposer des
solutions adaptées à nos territoires
j'ai relu rapport Borlo travaillait avec
200 mètres une association il y avait un
constat l'immobiliste à l'immobilisme
allait créer une nouvelle crise nous y
sommes il y avait nombreuses réponses
concrètes pour une réconciliation
nationale malheureusement ce fut un
rendez-vous manqué certes des choses ont
été faites mais si peu nous avons une
crainte que les solutions partielles
soient mises en place et que l'on passa
autre chose et qu'une autre crise
survienne au contraire il faut des
solutions globales forgées avec les élus
locaux les responsables associatifs
policiers médiateurs l'éducation
nationale nous avons appelé cela un
conseil des sages il convient donc de
reprendre le rapport Borlo madame la
Première ministre de l'actualisé les
valeurs de notre République ne peuvent
progresser que si la promesse d'égalité
possible ma question est simple quant
allons-nous construire enfin un destin
commun redonnant espoir à nos
concitoyens le président Macron y est-il
prêt en y associe en toutes les forces
vives de notre pays et enfin
reconstruire un monde plus humain plus
juste plus fraternel merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Bertrand pencher permettez-moi
d'abord de vous remercier pour votre
attitude profondément républicaine et
sans ambiguïté face aux violences
inacceptables qui ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours dans ces moments il est
essentiel que tous les élus attachés aux
valeurs de la République continue
[Musique]
à parler
oui vous avez un problème quand je parle
des élus attachés aux valeurs de la
République mesdames et messieurs les
députés
il est donc essentiel de tous les élus
attachés aux valeurs de la République
continue à parler d'une seule voix dans
un esprit républicain pour dénoncer les
violences les atteintes un qualifiables
aux élus et pour soutenir nos policiers
nos gendarmes et nos sapeurs-pompiers
alors comme vous je sais que le retour
au calme ne résoudra pas tout mais il
est le préalable indispensable à toute
action de long terme
viendra ensuite le temps des débats de
fonds mais je veux vous dire que pendant
six ans nous n'avons pas cessé d'agir
pour la politique de la ville vous
mentionnez le rapport de Jean-Louis
Borloo vous avez raison de le faire et
nous avons repris un grand nombre de ses
propositions nous avons conforté
l'Agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine en augmentant considérablement
son budget nous avons fait de
l'éducation et de la jeunesse des
piliers de la politique de la ville je
pense notamment aux cités éducatives que
nous avons créé pour lutter contre les
inégalités de destin et mieux structurer
les acteurs de terrain de la communauté
éducative je pense au dédoublement des
classes de CP et de CE1 que nous
étendons aux grandes sections et ça
n'est pas tout nous avons agi pour
l'emploi et si le taux de chômage est
encore trop élevé dans nos quartiers il
a baissé de 5 points depuis 2017 alors
monsieur le Président pencheur nous
sommes déterminés à travailler et agir
pour nos quartiers pour tout nos
territoires et nous le ferons pour tous
les élus engagés pour l'unité de notre
pays je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la Première ministre